President Trump recently upset one of
our closest allies Canada by placing
yeah well president Trump upset one of
our closest allies Canada by placing
some new tariffs on some of their
biggest exports check it out
steel and aluminum yeah Trump's
essentially causing a trade war with our
neighbors no one was expecting this many
people are of course quite unhappy no
one more so than one of our shows
Canadian writers actually he's our only
Canadian writer because you have to pay
him in Canadian money guys that's a
hassle anyway
true story really upset our one Canadian
writer Levi mcdougal so he asked he's
upset he's asked if he could come out
for a moment to deliver a strongly
worded statement to President Trump on
behalf of all Canadians yeah I saw Levi
this morning and it is the angriest I've
ever seen him yeah he's pretty he's
pretty pissed it's something he feels
needs to address so please welcome our
one Canadian writer Levi mcdougal
thanks.thanks going in thanks president
struck Oh hardly innit take it easy take
it easy
president Trump you decide to start a
trade war with us
Canada your friendly upstairs neighbors
and trade Wars well those aren't very
neighborly so on behalf of all my
country men and women
please listen very closely to what I'm
about to say hey don't leave I leave
like Levi please there's no need for
that kind of language I know of cloning
it I'm sorry but it's like Trump
unleashed a demon in me either
he wants to tax my country Steel will my
spine is forged from that very steel and
that's what gives me the courage to say
this if you tear off my spine I'll tear
off yours
that's uh that's a mic drop except you
don't really want to drop it that's an
expensive piece of equipment Levi get
ahold of yourself get ahold of your
president first and if he doesn't like
what I'm saying let's try something a
little more visual
president Trump looks straight at my
hand
[Music]
stop all right I'm sorry I'm sorry Levi
Lee yeah you just gone too far can we
get security in here okay come with me
mister okay look Conan I'm sorry but you
don't poke a sleeping bear unless you
want to cuddle hey good to see you you
shoot huzza way she's doing great
[Applause]
maybe mitre Levi mcdougal everybody
you